l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono farisei e today sono tornato
con il buon sasha mi ero perso nel bosco
adesso sono tornato ecco si sono trovati
su the forest godetevi l'episodio ma tu
sei dentro eccoti dentro la carica ti
ciao mi ero dimenticato che che sei nero
il problema è che tu sei messicano con
il trump non ti vuole
abbiamo costruito il muro attorno al
villaggio abbiamo fatto una stronzata
perché è notte cioè massimo dormiamo e
poi ci svegliamo la mattina capito che
vai a casa ruspa va bene questo ha avuto
uno spasmo bene direi che possiamo
andare a dormire sai che stai facendo
andiamo a dormire veloci che ci
ammazzano entra dentro la casa perché
non si può dormire in stagione che dormi
d'armi ho premuto z oddio ultimo ci
svegliamo la casa distrutta scommetti e
invece ci svegliamo che ancora notte che
palle ma che o perché soffre di insonnia
quanta gente c'è un accampamento di
profughi che fuori ci sono dalla casa in
testa di me barak e bordello dove lo sta
crollando di amazzoni come faccio devo
prendere la vita dall'asp e ci prova ha
rotto il cazzo ma guarda gente ci
ammazza li aiutò lo più di 7 società
andato mice pieno ci hanno invaso gianni
ma esce da lì sta andando a fuoco sasha
ha detto che diventi resuscito l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta ok lascia o dio che
cacchio c'è qua perché pienone di gente
aiuto a [ __ ] un attimo la tornate a
casa vostra ruspante motorie portello io
non ho mai visto è vabbè
mara mi stanno trascinando riferito lo
so ma non si arrivò al pieno di gente
hasan prima vai vai tranquillo
preoccupati gli occhi arrossati ore
stato veloce picchia li peschiamo 90 e
non è impresa che è simile come che si
rimetteva in un la cellino ll ora che
guarda come ridotta a casa nostra
bastardi vado in alto abbiamo messo una
vita
e voi negli hotel a cinque stelle e
renzi dove dove sono 1.080 euro sono
sembra pecora ottiene suscito di nuovo
dai dai di nuovo dai sta lanciando
l'avvocato ma che cazzo ciao ciao la
grande ora io sto sognando vivono in
casa è un sogno è un sogno si dorme
premi z per il z suono e giorno grazia
di dio ma il social lanciato una molotov
kakà ha posto a scherzando adesso
possono lanciare le moto non si stronzo
sto scherzando ma arrivato al molo dove
in testa va bene ea parte la vita che
ormai è scesa a [ __ ]
dobbiamo un attivo recupero bambi vieni
qua che avevamo bisogno di mangiare con
riva starr le micro cedu al boca gar le
palle solo perché era una vita che non
ci connette ma veramente perché erano in
casa avevano mai visto qualche lancia le
molla dall sono evoluti e mi sa che nel
frattempo si sono evoluti hanno capito
un usarle braccia prima erano solo da
decorazione bene cioè il coniglio che ho
preparato per cucinato per noi lo
cucinato per voi anche sei la luce anche
l'affetto così non è perché mangiare
qualcosa che buono lucertole conigli
cucinati anche un braccio la cosa ha
ucciso la madre quello buono neanche 12
anni
cosa ha bruciato è bellissimo ha fatto
un balletto stranissimo sarà come morto
cos'è sta o dio e il diavolo non volevo
cosa
ok bene sono stato di salve salve senta
guardi l'effige si è rotta ma la
ripariamo noi la facciamo
va bene io direi che se prendono ancora
qualche tronco per fare un paio di
almeno finire questa parte di qua
assolutamente sì vi ricordo che ci sono
i coccodrilli che non sono nostre ma già
porca eva i coccodrilli di merda che
cazzo ne ho trovato un pezzo di carne
per terra la mangiare così rapido prego
non cadere cade addosso al muro però non
lo sfondo d'aver non hanno sonda
perfetto dopo che è successo e l'ho
visto fare
[Risate]
addio
[Musica]
una testa a posto ecco non ci credo che
non ho il bastoncino incazzo per un
bastoncino di merda se non riusciamo a
fini sta roba
ma come se avete lo stuzzicadenti voi
che guardate il video un nome mi serve a
eccola trovato posto si bambino lo stava
potendo ma lo trovava credo è poi
vediamo non so se questo era questo ha
posto da fuoco io adesso pio porca
[ __ ] quanto sono rincoglionito
se io adesso prendo il coso qua di legna
dovrei riuscire a ma come faceva dalla
fuoco sono in acqua perchè immagini
maria de filippi e maurizio costanzo
nella in the forest bellissimo amari al
regio più delle indie gli indigeni dai
ragazzi fate il 3 loro indigeno si
chiama giorgio presentate lo farà papà
vedi che traggo entra l'indigeno tutto
lento para pappa paranza mangiare una
persona al pubblico arrivo forte
cos'è marcia [ __ ] o svecchiato la
slitta dobbiamo farla la porta anche a
sinistra è ben visibile 21 dove mandare
è porca [ __ ] quanto sono gasato che sta
finendo il muro non ha idea
sono contentissimo in parte cioè questi
prelievi che è finito ragazzi avevo
quasi finito il muro del nostro
scontento basta
ma perché io continuo a captare sta
cazzo di slitta di babbo natale può
accompagnare solo ecco allora su
picchiando una testa di gabbiano io se
guardi il muro che poi d'altro e
piccolissimo purtroppo che in mano come
cazzo fa essere così lungo quanto lo
quando lo metto va bene di mulo a
sinistra secondo me è prospettiva è così
una prospettiva dovete rilancio gli
spicci visto che mi sta offrendo da bere
sia amico te son 5 euro dove sono i miei
sor diamo al peggio di ok
l'ultimo onore a te no ma cos'è lo metto
4 f
allora poi lato gli aspetta l'abbia ma
dico poi passare qualche file come puoi
passare ma magari aveva servi qua ma
secondo me loro non ci passano perché
non sanno inchinarsi bene allora io
direi che possiamo entrare dormire visto
che ormai di notte non possiamo fare più
un cazzo e ci prepariamo ragazzi alla
spedizione della vita non so se
ricordate dov'eravamo rimasti
io sono nato boa per funghi e tu hai
trovato una grotta esatto bene ragazzi
miei dire che siamo pronti per la
spedizione della vita io abbiamo lo
zucchetto fatto di legno che proprio non
bancario proprio con questa porta
veramente [ __ ] si può chiudere a chiave
con la yeti condurrò nella caverna io mi
ricordo esattamente non è esattamente
non proprio meno mi ricordo dove tu non
hai idea di che cazzo è successo perché
l'ultima volta che siamo entrati nelle
caverne sai che abbiamo fatto tutto quel
casino per scendere nella voragine
io andando da una parte per il centro
hai trovato la l'entrata di quel posto
quindi potremmo scendere tranquillamente
rete della bagarre è esatto ed era
vicinissimo a casa che era giusto dietro
dove mori corri è no anche poca
staminali e cosa ceco lo corri acea
caparini zio tom
sei pronto quella che questo è un
viaggio non ha idea di che cosa
troveremo dentro perché te lo dico sa
incredibile ok ok
stiamo per entrare nella caverna della
vita ragazzi vita a banana era in
viaggio
aspettami solo nero sono il primo che
muoio come nei film non mi stai
sacrificando a sadhana vero no no no no
credimi non ho fatto un patto con
nessuno sono fuori li ho portati qua
perché ti amo e volevo farti la mia
dichiarazione così la scienza is rialza
scienza isri al andiamo a far vedere
questa allora qua ti chiederai come
cazzo si scende da una perché qua c'è
una ics come per dire possiamo
incollarci qualcosa per scendere un
rampino serve hai visto vorrei che figo
ma non è sceso così così si siano io ero
ero salito da qua perché io da possono
uscito non sono sceso capito che di
radio mutande sono rari coatto cosa vedi
quando fai st quando faccio sta cosa se
appeso al muro allora facciamo così il
problema sai cos'è che abbiamo uno solo
di sti cosi ha quindi come cazzo
scendiamo tutti e due tu non ce l'hai
questo vero nome della xv l'avevo
trovato di sotto quindi come cazzo si fa
accenno geo.mi schianto e tu mi viene da
allora ho paura di coda perché stavo
cadendo bene lo facciamo finta di niente
ma tu non è solo al buona mi sono
attenuto porca [ __ ] che carissima mai
tu hai fatto una place qua per il fondo
sono in fondo schiantati vive di vai
geronimo porca [ __ ] che botta allora
fermo da allora in teoria che io sappia
secondo me restaurato un altro di questi
picconi quindi prima o poi lo troveremo
ma nostra vita della roma condivisa
allora è risposato tutto quindi sono
risposati anche i medicinali credimi
allora vado al suono più avanti ci sono
poi il capitare c'è un tizio ci sono
pochi tizi ma ci sono quindi preparati
con un po combattere io ce l'ho fatta da
solo quindi in due ci dovremmo riuscire
problema è che non ho cose che
recuperano vista capito io ho capito
provo a dare qualche colpetto che
tranquillo ci penso io protesto hop 6
questa roba qua verde ragazzo in disco
sbocciava valdorme sulle torce giu c'e
la torcia e vero guarda c'è anche il
piccone c'è piccone cielo schiera torcia
che il piccone problema è che ci sono
due indigeni allora facciamo una roba
come fiumi d'acqua
allora io posso scendere nel solito modo
bocca vediamo se quasi una strada per
scendere per buttarsi in acqua tipo
senza morire
ok forse l'ho trovata seguimi
così almeno arriviamo tutti insieme e
non moriamo e buono ci sei
ma che diavolo di posta questo scendi
pianissimo scendi pianissimo è una e una
voragine gigantesca e sotto c'è l'acqua
come vede a checa
la prima volta ad ora guarda guarda la
guarda là dove dove sto guardando yo yo
la prima volta lì mi sono lanciato per
salvarmi da un indigeno è stato in
angolo sei caduto in acqua visto sala
tipo film allora dobbiamo prendere
assolutamente quel piccone e quindi
adesso scendiamo gli facciamo il culo
che hai sei pronto nove ragazzi nel
senso concludiamo che questo episodio
spero che i video vi sia piaciuto è che
consente ragazzi bisogna certamente è un
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook come
ad atene scrizione fateci sapere se
volete continuo che tanto noi faremo
perché ci divertiamo come dei bambini di
tre anni perfetta e quindi noi ci
rivediamo nel prossimo video non ho al
telecomando marchioro gioco cioè tutti
scriptum fate sega fantasia prezzi